we bring you all the updates on the vote
count plus all the allegations of voter
irregularity
president trump says he's only losing
thanks to voter fraud and democrats
launch an internal battle against
themselves as recriminations break out
over a rotten election day for democrats
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe at expressvpn.com we're
gonna get to all the news and there's
plenty of news today we'll get to all
that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you're
spending too much money on your cell
phone bill you are you're spending way
too much money on your cell phone bill
like probably hundreds of dollars too
much every year why well because
they're charging you for unlimited data
now are you using unlimited data of
course not because that's not possible
you can't use
unlimited data the reality is you are
using far less data than you are paying
for
what if there were a company that cut
down on all of that well that's what you
get with pure talk a veteran run
wireless company think att but much
better they understand what it means to
serve
verizon at t t-mobile if you're with
them you're overpaying pure and simple
pure talk can easily save you
over 400 bucks a year listen here's what
you need unlimited talk text and two
gigs of data
for just 20 bucks a month if you go over
on data usage they don't charge you for
it
so really there's no downside switching
to pure talk is the easiest decision you
will make today
you can keep your phone and your number
or you can get great deals on the latest
iphones
and android as well grab your mobile
phones out pound 250 say ben shapiro to
get started when you do
you'll save 50 off your first month dial
pound 2 five zero
say keyword ben shapiro they have a very
simple program they're offering you all
these other cell phone companies
they're gonna try and confuse you with
what exactly you're getting for your
money the answer is not much this is why
you should go check out pure talk by
dialing pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro pure talk is
simply smarter wireless
okay so here is where things stand right
now
pretty much everything's too close to
call pennsylvania too close to call
georgia too close to call arizona
too close to call and the election rests
on those three states trump needs all
three in order to win the election
michigan is out of range for him
wisconsin is out of range for him
despite allegations of voter
irregularities in michigan and wisconsin
all of which by the way
should be pursued because only legal
votes should be counted and all illegal
votes should not be counted
this is an uncontroversial statement the
fact is that the amount of voter
irregularity in michigan or wisconsin is
unlikely
to overcome the deficits that trump has
in those states which means that in
order for trump to win the election he
needs to win arizona
where the margin has been steadily
decreasing over time he needs to hold on
to georgia where the margin has also
steadily been decreasing over time but
in the opposite direction and he needs
to hold on to pennsylvania where the
margin has been decreasing also
in the wrong direction for trump over
the course of the last 48 hours
all of those states are too close to
call there will be litigation
in all of those states so a few
predicates before we get into the actual
news a few things
that we ought to discuss first of all
there's a lot of talk about voter
irregularity and voter fraud
these are real things that do happen
okay the scale of them is not tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
votes by the available evidence but
to pretend they do not happen is to
ignore the fact that they do in fact
happen and in fact
this has happened in places like
philadelphia in fact just back in may
reporting for the philadelphia inquirer
mensa dean and julie shaw
a former judge of elections and
democratic committee person from south
philadelphia
has pled guilty to accepting thousands
of dollars in bribes to inflate the vote
totals for three democratic candidates
for common pleas court judge in 2015
and for other democratic candidates for
office in 2014 and 2016
according to u.s attorney william mcswin
demuro 73 pled guilty to conspiracy to
deprive philadelphia voters of their
civil rights by fraudulently stuffing
the ballot box boxes for the judicial
candidates and for other candidates
seeking office in the 2014 and 2016
primary elections
he admitted violating the travel act
that forbids the use of a cell phone to
promote illegal activity as well
apparently demiro who could not be
reached for comment was paid between 300
and 5 000
for each election according to the
prosecutors demiro fraudulently stuffed
the ballot box by literally standing in
a voting booth and voting over and over
and over as fast as he could
while he thought the coast was clear
this is utterly reprehensible conduct
the charges announced today do not erase
what he did but they do ensure that he
has held account
for those actions demiuro admitted that
a political consultant paid him to add
votes for democratic candidates running
for the bench and other federal state
and local
offices as well in may 2014 zamiro
inflated vote totals by adding 27
fraudulent ballots in the primary
election 40 votes in may 2015 at 46 in
2016.
according to court documents outlining
the scheme and the charges against him
those numbers
may have seemed small but they made up a
significant percentage of the total
votes cast at that particular voting
place in 2014
118 total ballots were reported there
that meant bureau's fraudulent votes
accounted for over 22 percent
of the total voting in that division in
2014. so again
is that like a huge number of false
votes it's not a huge number
of false votes but you start to
aggregate stuff like that and it could
start to look kind of ugly
and this is also true if you look at the
possibility of voter fraud in
philadelphia if you're talking about for
example
the new pennsylvania court ruling that
went up to the supreme court and then
was remanded back down because the
supreme court didn't act on it
regarding when ballots are to be
accepted okay this is the really
controversial provision that went all
the way up to the supreme court
in which the state law is very clear
that you're only allowed to count
ballots
that have been received up to election
day and then they changed that because
of covid
and the the courts suggested they could
single-handedly re-write that so if a
ballot was received before
november 5th or 6th and if it was
postmarked as of election day
then it would be counted and even if
there was no countervailing evidence
that it was cast before the deadline
then it would be counted
right so those votes are apparently
technically being sequestered
it's unclear whether they're being
counted or not and then they'll have to
be uncounted and all that
the question really is the margins if
the margins are very large then this
sort of voter fraud is not going to
decide the election with that said
it undermines the integrity of our
elections that any of this is an issue
in the first place obviously okay so
that is issue number one
voter fraud voter regularity these are
real things are they hundreds of
thousands of votes
no are they tens of thousands of votes
probably not
are they thousands of votes maybe are
they hundreds of votes probably
okay so the margins of victory matter an
awful lot here
okay so that is just as by way of
background second
you actually need evidence to prove this
sort of stuff right so suspicion that
bad stuff is going on is not sufficient
to prove that voter fraud or voter
irregularity is responsible for the
outcome of an election
just like in everything else here on the
show we demand evidence of allegations
that are made
and the left is famous for suggesting
that evidence is unnecessary where it
doesn't support their narrative
and they will suggest that every white
cop shooting a black person is an act of
systemic american racism and then when
we go through the actual facts of the
case
it turns out that it is not and the left
will simply ignore that when allegations
are made
of a particular criminal activity it
seems to me there should be evidence
of that criminal activity so all of the
allegations should be investigated
all of it should come out all of the
lawsuits should be filed and we should
all just take a chill pill and wait a
little bit i understand everybody wants
to know the outcome of the election i
understand
everybody is impatient but guess what if
we find out on monday who won the
election or if we find out two weeks
from monday who won the election
based on the investigation of all of
these allegations the world will not be
materially changed in any way because
all the votes have already been cast
okay that's the end of the story and the
the rush
by media outlets who want to announce
this thing the rush
by democrats who want to announce an
outcome the rush that you're getting
from
various members of the media going to
foreign countries and saying look how
humiliated america is and
like why in the world would i care what
the germans think of our election the
only reason
they can even hold elections is because
we gave them elections if it were not
for us elections would not be a thing in
germany
so i'm really not interested in hearing
from the german government
exactly what they think of our free and
fair elections here in the united states
so everybody needs to take a chill pill
and let the process play out is i guess
what i'm saying here
and we should always make sure that
serious allegations
are supported and that allegations are
support hubble
okay so that's point number one endpoint
number two point number three
democrats are very upset today because
president trump did a presser
yesterday in which he declared basically
the only way that he can lose
is through voter fraud now we'll get to
the actual the actual allegations
trump is making there in just one second
suffice it to say that on the democrat
on the democratic side of the aisle they
have not only no leg to stand on they do
not have stumps of legs to stand on
on this particular point okay democrats
do not get to claim
that they are deeply upset about the
undermining of the legitimacy of
american elections after spending
four years claiming that the 2016
election was a giant bamboozle
by the russians they do not get to claim
that they respect the outcome of
elections when they still trot out
stacey abrams as the governor of georgia
after she lost by 50
000 votes in georgia that's not the way
this works
you guys don't get to run around
claiming that you deeply respect the
outcome of every election you want every
vote counted
and then use al gore as your baton to
say that
okay i'm not just making up that
democrats don't respect the outcomes of
elections they don't like
they literally do not respect the
outcomes of elections they don't like
so i don't like that from any side of
the aisle okay once all the votes are in
once all the votes have been counted
once we root out any impropriety
that's the election and that's the end
of it and that should be a non-partisan
statement
it happens to be a truth that democrats
have not accepted the results of the
2016 election and never did so it's very
difficult to hear from people like
hillary clinton
that now donald trump is supposed to
preemptively concede the race before all
of the legalities
are gone through right here was hillary
clinton just about
a week ago suggesting that the election
of 2016 was stolen from her using
exactly the kind of language that she
now decries trump using
there's an air of illegitimacy that
surrounds trump's presidency and
that just infuriates them it makes them
crazy
and that's a big piece of it so they
have to keep
striking out at me because why you why
well because i was the candidate that
they basically stole an election from i
was the candidate who won
you know nearly three million more votes
they basically stole the election guys
and she's not even talking about voter
fraud or voter irregularity she's saying
the process
actually working amounts to stealing
right she says that i won more votes
than trump on a roll it's not a popular
vote contest lady
this was and still is the prevailing
notion in the democratic party so
hearing about the undermining of
american elections from hillary clinton
today and from her allies today that's
pretty rich stuff
it's also pretty rich to hear from al
gore so you'll recall 2000
if you're old enough i was 16 in 2000
and i remember that was that's really
the first national election
that i remember in any detail because it
was such a big thing right i mean it got
litigated for a month
al gore was being trotted out by msnbc
today as a proprietor of
election legality he was trotted out by
msnbc
where he promptly explained that he was
a great defender
of every vote being counted here was al
gore
that the same guy who basically forced
us to go through
over a month of election confusion
before the supreme court settled bush v
gore in 2000 claiming
that he is definitely a person who
stands up for uh for election legality
but the most important principle that i
defended 20 years ago
that joe biden and many others are
defending
tonight is let's count every
legally cast vote and obey the will
of the american people my favorite thing
there
is when al gore says and i do love it
when al gore says
that he defends every vote right that
was his big thing
right um no some of us have memories
right al gore saying he defended
counting every legally cast ballot
that's pure retconning it just isn't
true
he tries to disenfranchise military
ballots the only reason he didn't
get away with it is because joe
lieberman went on national tv and said
they weren't doing that
and people in the gore campaign
apparently were pretty pissed according
to contemporaneous accounts
he also demanded recounts only in the
areas where he thought he was going to
win
and in those recounts he wanted people
to divine voter intent that was the
pregnant chad controversy if you
remember
all that now pregnant chad connotes the
media's view of men getting pregnant but
back then a pregnant chad was just you
tried to
vote and you may have dinged a chad but
you didn't actually punch it through
on a punch card and therefore we tried
to divine your intent by looking into
our heart it was a really really silly
time
and al gore was the guy standing behind
that he wanted ballots counted that
weren't properly cast
he didn't want properly cast ballots
counted and now harry is lecturing us
all on election propriety like spare me
spare me just a little bit okay in just
a second i'm gonna get to
all of the latest updates from
pennsylvania with regard to some of
these
voter impropriety allegations and
michigan and uh and nevada we'll get to
all of that
in just one second first let's talk
about something awkward you ready
something like erectile dysfunction yep
that was pretty awkward wasn't it but
here's the thing if you're suffering
from it
that awkwardness may be preventing you
from getting the health care that you
need
this is why you need to check out roman
with roman you get a free online
evaluation and ongoing care 4d all from
the comfort and privacy of your home
a healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate
roman will ship you real medicine with
free two-day shipping the whole process
is straightforward simple and discreet
getting started is really easy just go
to getroman.com ben
complete an online visit ed used to be
tough to talk about now there is roman
complete online visit today connect with
the doctor
get this issue taken care of a lot of
people will live with a medical issue
just because it's embarrassing or
annoying to get it taken care of this is
not a medical issue you want to live
with you want to go get it solved and
you can do it quickly and easily and
inexpensively
head on over to getroman.com ben get up
to 50 bucks off your first month of ed
treatment a free online visit and free
two-day shipping
that's getroman.com for up to 50 bucks
off your first month
of ed treatment getroman.com ben again
that's g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n-com
ben go check them out right now okay so
here is the actual
latest when it comes to developments in
pennsylvania as i say that race is too
close to call
trump was up a significant number of
ballots and now the thing is basically a
dead heat
same thing is happening down in georgia
where briefly this morning joe biden
leapt into the lead military ballots
still have to be counted
presumably those will split on in favor
of president trump you would think
there's some provisional ballots that
still have to be counted so a lot of
these states are still
up in the air there's a lot of
controversy over the last 24 hours
because the trump campaign filed a
lawsuit
and now the appellate commonwealth court
of pennsylvania has sided
with team trump rejecting a deadline
extension for absentee voters to provide
missing proof of identification
and so basically the democrats wanted
people to have like three weeks or
a month or some extended period of time
to show that they were who they said
that they were
and uh that did not materialize
according to the rnc
and a huge victory for election
integrity the commonwealth court of
pennsylvania
sided with the rnc and donald trump in
the challenge to secretary bukvar's
unlawful deadline extension for absentee
voters to provide missing proof of
identification
the court has enforced the proper
statutory deadline and ordered that
those ballots be segregated and not
counted
rnc chairwoman ron mcdaniel said the rnc
is doing everything in our power to
ensure these kinds of issues are
resolved and the letter of the law
is followed right so again all of this
is worthwhile the letter of the law
should be followed okay also a
pennsylvania court
did mandate access to poll watchers
okay according to dailywire.com tim
pearce
reporting in pennsylvania ruled on
thursday morning gop observers must be
allowed to watch ballot counting
across the state apparently they ruled
that gop observers could watch
the ballot count from six feet away but
they had been pushed out to like 16
or 100 feet away the court order allows
gop observers to stand
closer previously they'd been using
binoculars
the trump campaign of course had
preemptively declared victory in
pennsylvania yesterday suggesting that
the uh the number of ballots
is uh is too big for it for biden to
overcome we'll see whether that is in
fact
the case okay now as to the actual
claims of election fraud
in philadelphia that have been made at
this point
some are somewhat substantiable some are
really
not they should all be investigated as i
keep saying
so president trump said last night that
partisan democrats have allowed the
ballots to be received three days after
the election we think much more than
that
well election officials will be counting
ballots that will receive between 8 pm
on election day and 5 pm on friday
and again that is the big issue right
because that
preliminary ruling suggested that as
long as there was no countervailing
evidence
to suggest that the ballots were cast
before election day they have to be
counted so unpostmarked ballots could be
counted okay that's crazy that's crazy
and that will end up back in the supreme
court
and presumably there will be a ruling on
that now is that
tens of thousands of votes probably not
is it hundreds of votes
could be could be and i'm sure that all
of them will be forbidden
okay president trump also suggested that
uh they are counting these votes in
pennsylvania without any id whatsoever
as the philadelphia inquirer says
pennsylvania requires people voting in
person to provide
proof of identity if it is their first
time voting at that precinct
that's also required from anyone
registering for a mail-in ballot
apparently the pennsylvania secretary of
state has advised the ballots should not
be counted if a name on a mailing ballot
cannot be verified or if identification
was not received and this is where the
trump campaign came in and they said
okay you don't get a week or a week and
a half to provide id
like you should have done it at the time
it is also true
that the trump campaign was pointing out
that republican election observers
were being forbidden from viewing the
vote count
closely in person now city lawyers for
philadelphia say the gop representatives
observing the accounting could see the
entire setup of the canvassing room
and could watch every detail of the
accounting process
a lawyer representing the trump campaign
did tell a judge there have been
representatives of the campaign
observing the counting
process the city solicitor marcel pratt
said in a statement
many representatives of the trump
campaign have been given access to the
convention center throughout the entire
day and since tuesday just like
observers from other campaigns the board
has set up a location from which
candidates and party representatives
potentially in large numbers can easily
view the room without impeding
the operation that is according to the
city solicitor
but again why would you be filing a
lawsuit if it weren't the case that you
were actually being prevented
from seeing what in the hell was going
on
this led to a bit of a confrontation
between team trump and philadelphia
officials
now it is unclear whether the
philadelphia officials are stonewalling
what are they violating the law here
so take all these videos with grain of
salt because very often
these videos are slightly out of context
one of the allegations i saw here is
that the court order being shown
was in order to remand back to the local
court for a final order
and that the election officials here
were waiting for the final order in any
case here is what that sounded like in
philadelphia
assure yesterday that they're not
violating it the order is currently in
effect
you're not violating you guys had eight
attorneys i think it was eight attorneys
entering your appearance on this
i don't understand why eight attorneys
need to evaluate this order i did it all
by myself
it says that no later than 10 30 today
you're to follow the election code and
my people
my clients representatives are to be
within six feet of the process
okay so that was attorney general former
florida attorney general pam bondi who
is a lawyer
for the campaign he said we plan on
entering that building right now and
legal observing legally observing if
there's one illegal vote cast it takes
away from the great men and women of
pennsylvania who came out and issued
a legal vote and then she updated later
she said this is a joke they move the
fence up but move the ballot machines
back this is offensive
and uh obviously we should we should
change that particular standard so that
is where things
stand right now okay so obviously these
sorts of controversies are not good for
the american public
and we need to know all the details of
them and they should all be fully
investigated
in a second we'll get to the response
from the pennsylvania secretary of state
okay we'll get to that in one second
first let us talk about the fact right
now not a great time to go to an auto
parts store in fact never is a great
time to go to an auto parts store you
stand in line for a long time then you
finally get up front and then you have
to answer a bunch of questions you don't
know the answers to and then they order
a generic part online and then they up
charge you
or you could just go online and do this
yourself head on over to rockauto.com
they always offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years
head on over to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts the rockauto.com catalog
is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer
there's amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need
rockauto.com why would you spend too
much money when you don't have to shop
competitively at rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
write shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box
so they know that we sent you so the
pennsylvania secretary of state buchvar
right who've mentioned several times
here she is very partisan
she had tweeted a lot about how bad
trump is she's a democrat but she says
listen i took an oath of office so i'm
not cheating the system we have the same
sort of uh of statements from the
pennsylvania a.g josh shapiro says all
the votes are going to be counted
i remember that time i tweeted last week
about how when all the votes are counted
biden's going to win
just ignore that it turns out that when
you have partisan officials in charge of
elections people tend to get pretty
suspicious
here it was bhuvari yesterday look these
were four years ago
and at the time i was not in the
administration i was not in any public
service i was a private citizen it was a
personal twitter account
um and you know i so
so that and then when i became secretary
of state
i took an oath dennis and i took an oath
to defend
and and protect the constitution of the
commonwealth of pennsylvania and the
constitution in the united states
and partisan politics have no place
in the pennsylvania department of state
or any county elections office
okay so you know again is there a reason
for people to be suspicious
sure is there is there a reason to
declare the entire election illegitimate
yet
no should we see all the evidence come
out absolutely
and should everybody just take a chill
pill and wait for a second while we do
all these investigations and while the
legal process moves forward
yes okay meanwhile in nevada similar
accusations being made the nevada gop
put out a tweet yesterday saying our
lawyers just sent a criminal referral to
a.g barr
regarding at least 3062 instances of
voter fraud we expect that number to
grow substantially
thousands of individuals have been
identified who appear to have violated
the law by casting ballots
after they moved from nevada this is one
of the big problems with mail-in ballots
generally
seriously it's a real problem with
mail-in ballots and it's been a problem
for a long time
right jimmy carter once said that mail
and ballots were rife with the
possibility of fraud
i mean this makes perfect sense right i
i just moved from california to florida
shortly before the election
and then i had my mail forwarded to me
right so i looked in my mail and there
they were
my california ballot and my california
ballots arrived in florida now
where i an unscrupulous person i could
theoretically fill out those ballots
vote in california and then also vote in
florida i wouldn't do that because it's
illegal and because it's immoral
but could people do that of course when
you send out a bunch of ballots to
people's addresses assuming they still
live there
that does open the possibility of voter
fraud could somebody have
come by my house and picked up the mail
in my mailbox while i wasn't there and
filled those out and i don't live there
anymore and then the ballot gets
sure i mean the possibilities of voter
fraud are real that does not mean that
the evidence of voter fraud is
necessarily going to materialize in the
numbers
that you would need in order to shift a
major national election
with that said the nevada gop did issue
a letter
to the clark county nevada district
attorney alleging a voter fraud by
people who are not legal residents
of clark county the firm of weir law
group llc
sent a letter to marianne miller who is
in indeed the clark county nevada
district attorney
suggesting that a bunch of illegal
ballots have been accepted
they say this firm in conjunction with
harvey and benelli pllc represents
donald trump for president as you know
we've been concerned for months
about improper ballots being cast in the
2020 general election
yet joseph gloria has yet to take any
reasonably basic and fundamental steps
to ensure male ballots are free from
fraud and abuse
his inaction has had and continues to
have material adverse consequences on
our election security we have confirmed
thousands of votes have been cast
improperly
indeed we have initially identified over
3 000 voters who moved from nevada
before the election but still cast
ballots in this election
we verified this by cross-referencing
the list of general election voters with
publicly available change of address
records for example
demographic experts agree the national
change of address database only captures
about one-third of relocations
so we think that this number will likely
grow by 6 000 voters at a minimum
okay well that starts to look closer to
the margin of error
in nevada given the current vote counts
okay so again all of this
should be checked into now does that
mean that every allegation of voter
fraud is real
no doesn't mean that every voter
irregularity report is real no
it does mean once again for the one
thousandth time just as i said earlier
this week
you shouldn't declare victory in an
election until all the votes have been
counted
this holds true for every single side
and i am amused at the democrats who say
that this is only true
so long as donald trump is declaring
victory but it is not true if joe biden
or his team are declaring victory if the
democrats declare victory we all go home
happy
if the republicans declare victory
they're very immoral and bad that is the
way the logic of the media and the
democrats work we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about hiring so
let's say that you have an excellent
employee generally excellent employee
but let's say that it's been a really
long week a really really long week and
let's say that
this particular employee well i'm not
naming any names but they ran with
colton haas
let's let's just say that that employee
decides that you know
friday morning time to get a little lazy
it's a lazy friday
you know let's just just let's ease off
a little bit sure the election could be
theoretically called by major media
outlets today but i'm just going to
arrive like you know like 45 minutes
late to the show
and but and then and then announced that
i had a really good sleep well at that
point
you might want to head on over to
ziprecruiter.com
zip recruiter will do all the work you
need them to do because they will help
you fill
those jobs such as if you were going to
hire in replacement for the
aforementioned colton haas first when
you post a job on zip recruiter it gets
sent out
to over 100 job sites with just one
click then zip recruiter's powerful
matching technology finds people with
the right skills and experience for your
job
and actively invites them to apply so
you get qualified candidates fast it is
no wonder
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter gets a quality candidate
within
the very first day right now try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
upgrade your employees today or find a
great employer today
over at ziprecruiter.com dailywire you
can try it out for free
zip recruiter.com dailywear okay so over
in nevada again the trump campaign
putting a lot of focus
on the possibility of voter fraud and
voter regularity rick grinnell
who is obviously a member of team trump
an ambassador to germany he says
we are not being allowed to check the
votes ballots
are not automatically legal votes
until they're checked we are not being
allowed
to check the harry reid machine
recklessly threw ballots into the mail
and now we cannot check
whether or not there are non-residents
which we have
evidence publicly available evidence
that you all in the media should be also
looking at
alrighty so there is rick grinnell
saying that the votes have not been
checked there
the former ag of nevada adam mcsalt he
also said that he thinks that there is a
lot of mail and fraud
we firmly believe that there are many
voters
in this group of mail-in people that are
not
proper voters in the last many days
we have received reports of many
irregularities
across the valley we believe that there
are dead voters
that have been counted we are also
confident that there are thousands
of people whose votes have been counted
that have moved out of clark county
in the during the pandemic the trump
campaign also
brought forth a woman named jill stokey
who claims that somebody took her ballot
and voted on
her behalf here's what she had to say
yesterday my name is jill stokey
i went to vote it was told by a remote i
pursued the matter
and in years past i always voted in
person
this time they mailed out the ballot and
somebody
took my ballot they also took the ballot
of my roommate
i was told by the interviewer from
channel 8
when i said did other people do this he
said yes
he said you're the first okay a clark
county registrar then said
well we then talked to her and uh we
checked her signature it matched and we
offered her the opportunity to revoke
and she turned it down so again not
every allegation of voter fraud or voter
regularity ends up being
true this is why evidence is usually
necessary here's the clark county
registrar
i personally dealt with miss stoke she
brought her claim to me
we reviewed the ballot and in our
opinion it's her signature
we also gave her an opportunity to
provide a statement
if she wanted to object to that and
provide a challenge to that she refused
to do so
a member of the nevada secretary of
state's office investigation team
also interviewed her and they had no
issue with the
assistance that we tried to give her
okay so
you know all of this will be litigated
all of this will be litigated and that's
really what it's going to come down to
because
as of today the network started calling
the election for joe biden biden pulled
ahead in pennsylvania
a lot of the mail-in ballots that were
still coming in from surrounding
counties
10 toward the heavily democratic trump
is making the claim that voter
regularity is responsible for this
we're going to see it all litigated out
okay so that brings us to president
trump's presser last night so president
trump came out last night
and he uh he said some true things he
said some things that were not so true
it drove
people absolutely badly here was
president trump yesterday he emerged
to say you know there's a lot of talk in
the lead-up to the election about a big
blue wave that just did not materialize
he was president trump last night
as everybody saw we won by historic
numbers
and the pollsters got it knowingly wrong
they got it knowingly wrong
we had polls that were so ridiculous and
everybody knew it at the time there was
no blue wave that they predicted
they thought there was going to be a big
blue wave that was false that was done
for
suppression reasons but instead there
was a big
red wave and it's been properly
acknowledged actually by the media
okay okay he's right about that
obviously the fact is that republicans
far outperformed what the polls
suggested republicans are going to end
up with maybe 214 seats
in the house which is an unthinkable
outcome cook political which was a
non-partisan outlet was suggesting
republicans were going to lose anywhere
from five to 10 seats instead
republicans
are going to pick up anywhere from 10 to
15 seats in the in the house of
representatives
plus there's a likelihood that they
maintain the senate i know there's a lot
of heartburn out there about the two
georgia senate races which are both
likely going
to run off at this point okay i'm fairly
sanguine about those races the reason
i'm fairly sanguine about those races is
because
donald trump is not going to be on the
ballot in georgia what we've seen across
the country
a lot of democratic ballots where it's
just joe biden and nothing underneath
meaning the motivation to get out for a
special election in georgia for senate
just to give control to chuck schumer
it's not really there for democrats in
huge numbers for republicans to stop
chuck schumer and joe biden from having
unified control of government lots and
lots of motivation
plus the reality is that uh the one one
of the races and
david david perdue in that race he did
beat the democrat he just didn't get
directly above 50 percent he ended up
like right at 50 percent
in the other race kelly luffler who's
going to be the candidate she's going to
unify republican support behind her doug
collins and kelly lefler split the
support
in that particular race but they were
outpolling the democrat in that race
anyway so i think the republicans end up
with both of those
ga senate seats okay so trump is right
there was in fact a big red wave but
he's also right it was the year of the
republican woman and because the media
hate republicans they just decided
they're not going to comment on it
this was also the year of the republican
woman
more republican women were elected to
congress than
ever before that's a great achievement
alrighty so he is right about that as
well then we get to the crux of the
matter right we get to the heart of the
matter that people are upset about we'll
get to that in just
one second first let us talk about how
you can really upgrade your business in
a quick
and easy way business owners did you
know 97
of text messages get open 90 are open
within three minutes you need to be
texting
your customers if you spend time on the
phone scheduling appointments you need
podium this is what podium does podium
makes sure that your business
is transferred over to the text message
realm if a business emails me it usually
goes into my spam file
if they try to call me i'm not picking
up unless i know the number if they text
me
then i am likely to actually take a look
at the text this is something
that podium knows if you're sending
invoices in the mail you need podium if
you need to convert more sales from your
website you need podium
podium is a business messaging tool it
gets you off the phone and into texting
if you're not using texting to reach
your customers you're leaving money
on the table podium customers have seen
some fantastic results recently a
plumbing company converting 16 percent
of their web traffic into leads a
national retailer collecting 18 000
reviews across its locations a property
management
company increasing revenue by 20 podium
is doing everything from helping doctors
to notify patients when it's time for
them to come inside for their
appointments
to helping retailers offer curbside
pickup or helping car dealers sell cars
and deliver them to buyers
it's indispensable for a limited time
sign up for 20
off your plan with podium they're so
confident that if podium doesn't make
your business better within 90 days
they'll send you a 150
amazon gift card for the holidays which
is a pretty amazing deal go to
podium.com
shapiro to get started that's 20 percent
off if you go to p-o-d-i-u-m-podium.com
apparel again head on over to podium.com
shapiro
today okay so then we get to the crux of
uh trump's press conference and this is
where
this is going to launch a thousand thing
pieces president trump suggests that the
election
has been stolen from him via voter fraud
and voter irregularities as they are
trying to steal
the election now is this an
overstatement
i think it's an overstatement because i
don't know that they're trying to steal
an election
i do think that any suspicion of voter
fraud and voter regularity should be
pursued it's very important to the
country
that transparency be the byword of the
day
right it depends on who the they is it
depends on what evidence there is
obviously
here's president trump saying that
they're trying to steal an election
there's tremendous litigation going on
and this is a case where they're trying
to steal an election
they're trying to rig an election and we
can't let that happen detroit and
philadelphia known as two of the most
corrupt political places
anywhere in our country easily
cannot be responsible for engineering
the outcome of
a presidential race a very important
presidential race
now the reality is that you want to make
sure that everything is not corrupt so
any call by president trump to make the
process less corrupt is
is a good call trump then continues to
say they never believed they could win
this honestly
democrat officials never believed they
could win this election honestly i
really believe
that that's why they did the mail-in
ballots where there's tremendous
corruption and fraud going on that's why
they
mailed out tens of millions of
unsolicited ballots without any
verification measures whatsoever
and i've told everybody that these
things would happen
because i've seen it happen okay his
complaints about the mail and balloting
process as i've talked about
at length on the program before i think
are not unjustified i think that the
mailing ballasting process
can be a problem is that evidence that
it was a problem here or that it makes
up the margin of error in these various
states the margin of differential
no it doesn't and this is where trump
goes too far right he says if you count
all the votes legally i'm going to win
if you don't count all the votes legally
if you count a bunch of illegal votes
they're stealing
the election how about this how about
i'm filing all the lawsuits that are
necessary in order to ensure that the
vote count is fair
i suspect that there are many
outstanding ballots that are being
unfairly counted
you know that that would that's
perfectly legit him suggesting the only
way for him to lose his voter fraud or
voter illegality is obviously a broad
overstatement but
the president trafficks in those if you
count the
legal votes i easily win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us if you count
the votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
okay so you know him saying that that if
you count the votes that came in late
but we don't know the numbers on that
that's obviously something that should
be litigated if in fact that is the
margin of error
in pennsylvania and finally trump
concludes we're going to take all the
legal action at our disposal
to ensure that only legally cast ballots
are counted which of course is legit i
mean that's
that's perfectly fine that's perfectly
fine for any candidate it's to file any
legal challenge that they feel is
appropriate in order to ensure the
veracity of the ballot here is trump
i have been talking about this for many
months with all of you
and i've said very strongly that mail-in
ballots are going to end up being a
disaster small
elections were a disaster small very
easy to handle elections
were disastrous this is a large scale
version and it's getting worse and worse
every day we're hearing
stories that are horror stories absolute
horror stories
and we can't let that happen to the
united states of america it's not a
question of who wins
republican democrat joe myself
we can't let that happen to our country
okay so
the legal process will move forward a
president will be declared that is the
way this is going to work the media
obviously
jumping the gun because this is what
they do right they're in the business of
projecting states they currently project
that joe biden
is the president of the united states
decision desk hq called it earlier today
nbc news called it earlier today
they called it earlier today based on
biden taking a lead in pennsylvania
again
this has not been litigated yet this has
not gone all the way through
the process okay and journalists were
fighting mad about trump saying this
stuff
they were fighting fighting mad now as i
say for trump to suggest that the only
way he can lose is if it was voter fraud
or voter irregularity is an
overstatement he said it earlier this
week and i said it was wrong for him to
say it then and it's wrong for him to
say it now
and he should not be saying because no
one should i mean
we saw democrats saying it's wrong when
democrats say it it's wrong when
democrats
suggest that the only way that they
could lose is through voter suppression
right i've been on this bandwagon for a
while now
that it turns out that sometimes
elections go the way you don't want them
to but
for the media to immediately dismiss all
possibility of voter fraud and voter
irregularity or to suggest that anybody
who's worried about that is a dupe or an
idiot
that's not right that's not right at all
okay so journalists
of course journalism's all over the
place they lost it
so jim acosta and ladies find you
somebody find you
anybody who loves you like jim acosta
loves jim acosta here is jim acosta
now celebrating trump's presidency is
disappearing before our eyes i can't
imagine
why the trust in institutional media is
at all time lows because this guy's an
objective journalist who's tubing all
over the place
the president is watching the lights go
out on his presidency right now
that is what we're witnessing in real
time as these votes are being tabulated
and joe biden is catching up in
pennsylvania
and in georgia the the presidency of
donald
j trump is vanishing before our eyes
okay weird i don't remember them saying
this about al gore during the challenges
of 2000 i don't remember anybody at cnn
suggesting that stacey abrams was full
of crap after she declared that voter
suppression was the rationale for losing
her georgia gubernatorial race i
remember everybody at cnn for four long
years declaring that donald trump was
illegally made president by the russians
okay so no i i don't buy this kind of
high dungeon nonsense
from jim acosta from anderson cooper
anderson cooper came out he trashed
trump as pathetic
which of course again you really want to
up the your the faith in an objective
media continue along these lines here's
anderson cooper
it's sad and it is truly pathetic and of
course it is dangerous and of course it
will
go to courts but you'll notice the
president did not have any evidence
that is the president of the united
states that is the most powerful person
in the world
and we see him like an obese turtle on
his back
flailing in the hot sun realizing his
time is over
oh that's that's a reporter who's
reporting without animus right
there yeah i mean it's amazing i'm sorry
that
the media saying that trump wants to
take the country down with them yes our
objective media declaring the president
a fat turtle on his back
in the sun yes i'm sure you guys
slow clap for the journalistic
establishment here really really well
done really well done
you know on cnn i'd say probably four
years ago at this point i said you guys
need to take the
the journalism up to an 11 and you need
to take the tenor down to a one
and they have decided to do precisely
the opposite and they're just going to
assume
out of hand that anything trump says is
unworthy of even
considering the possibility of they're
going to get into high dungeon
and then they're going to do the what
makes anderson cooper as a reporter
distinguishable from rachel maddow i'm
missing it i don't i don't see anything
i really don't okay well here is the
truth and we're getting this in a second
the reason that the democrats are
focusing in on trump and they're
focusing on the trump biden race
is because there is something else that
happened in the election last night
and uh they don't like it very much
there is significant
unrest in the democratic party the
democratic party is on the verge of a
breakup
they have way bigger problems than the
republican party regardless of what
happens with all the lawsuits regardless
of what happens at the top of the ticket
i know everybody wants to pay attention
to that
the fact is election night was a
terrible night for democrats a terrible
night for democrats they lost 100 state
legislative seats all over the country
they lost state legislatures in new
hampshire they lost the governorship in
montana
they did not pick up any of the state
legislatures they needed in a
redistricting year
they are they are devastated and they
should be devastated the democratic
coalition
is not workable it is not a workable
coalition that is becoming clearer and
clearer clearer every day
and i have the evidence right in front
of me we'll get to that in just one
second because
the democrats are in fact in disarray
and they are on the verge of collapse
and the only thing that is masking that
is the possibility
of a 78 year old geriatric half senile
man
supposedly going to act as the glue of
the party good luck with that gang
good luck good luck even if joe biden
emerges victorious we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the watch that you wear upon your
wrist right now so
there are a lot of people out there who
are going to try and sell you really
really cheap watches for very expensive
prices
what if you could get a really quality
watch at a price that
you're willing to pay i'm talking of
course about vincero ventura is
dedicated to the craft they put time and
effort into crafting timepieces so you
can wear them day after day after day my
dad wears vincero my wife wears vincero
trust me i wear vincero too i talk about
this brand often because i believe in
the products they make
head on over to vincerowatches.com
shapiro don't hesitate right now
they're having a site-wide sale up to 20
off anything on this i mean these things
look like luxury watches so check this
sucker out
right this right here this venture watch
i think it's beautiful i think it's a
beautiful timepiece
and i lo i'm a watch guy i love
timepieces at this
at this price excellent excellent stuff
they promise you solid well-made
products you will enjoy wearing they
know how important it is to shop from
local brands you can trust ventura
offers free shipping 30 day returns
guarantees your watch for two years
that's why they've made over 25 000
five-star reviews because you won't find
a better maid watch for this kind of
price
anywhere else my listeners have been the
hero for ventura this year seriously the
folks at ventura they say they're
extremely grateful for all your support
in a
down economic time so keep the emails
messages letters going most importantly
keep supporting this show and this brand
continue to support the brand as they
support the show go to vincero watches
v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches dot com shapiro take advantage
of the sale opportunity go get one of my
go-to watches at a fantastic price
these are great watches to wear i give
them as gifts all the time go check out
vincerowatches.com shapiro again that is
v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches dot com
shapiro already we're gonna get to the
absolute disarray in the democratic
party because that really is the story
coming out of the election
i understand everybody still wants to
focus in
on the presidential election the reality
is this was a bad election for democrats
a very bad election for democrats and
that's why you're still seeing
an enormous amount of despair in
democratic circles so wait until i tell
you about this it's pretty incredible
first you don't want to miss another
great episode of the sunday special
coming up this weekend we'll be joined
by historian victor davis hanson to
discuss
president trump his legacy for the
republican party we'll be discussing
america's context in history because he
is a historian what does america most
resemble are we the roman empire are we
the roman republic like where are we in
history right now looking at the united
states
head on over and watch early at
dailywire.com or listen to sunday on
apple podcast spotify or wherever else
you get your podcast
also you may have noticed this has been
an insane year you may have noticed that
there is a movement of foot to basically
rip away american history the woke
skulls are out there to ruin your life
and censor you you may have noticed that
there is a real divide in american
philosophy right now the number one
question i get i get it all the time
from parents
and from teachers and from just general
people how do i get the people around me
to understand american philosophy
right how do what do you mean when you
talk about the declaration or the
constitution
and what do you mean when you talk about
there are people who want to overthrow
that stuff why would they want to do
that i wrote a book it's called how to
destroy america in three easy steps it
is more relevant than it was the day of
the election
this is the battle that is going to
characterize america going forward joe
biden
represents a facade for the
disintegrationists
that has to stop go pick up a copy right
now how to destroy america in three easy
steps today
at amazon or barnesandnoble.com you're
listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile the democratic party is in
complete disarray
so don't let all of the focus on trump
versus biden fool you the democratic
party has deep deep troubles they lost a
bunch of seats across the country
and they are just they can't stand it i
mean they're falling apart
the dccc chair a woman named sherry
bustos she told house democrats per
person on a house democrat call
yesterday quote
i'm furious something went wrong here
across the entire political world
something went wrong here across the
entire political world well first of all
let me just say this the democratic
party needs to start using zip recruiter
asap
like asap do you have any idea who's the
head of the dccc
democratic congressional campaign
committee you know who that was
the the head of the democratic
congressional campaign committee
is robbie mook you know what robbie mook
did before he was the head of the dccc
he was the head of hillary clinton's
presidential campaign in 2016.
okay that qualifies you for only one job
head coach for the new york jets
that is the only job that qualifies you
for seriously like that's an amazing
record
i love that can you imagine how that
interview went
he walks into the dccc they're like oh
robbie good to see you and he's like oh
good to see you too they're like well
what did you do what was your last job
it's like i ran the most unsuccessful
presidential campaign in american
history
they're like you are hired my friend
it's probably gonna go great
and then the dccc obviously immediately
falls apart
on the job so there's a massive internal
democratic meltdown
yesterday there's the democratic caucus
call and i'm going to read this to you
in its entirety because it is so
indicative
of the fact that the democratic
coalition cannot hold
so democrats since 2012 have been
attempting to replicate the obama
coalition
right the obama coalition was going to
be minorities
gays some suburban women
some woke white folks and that was going
to overturn
the the other 47 of the population was a
new ascendant
plurality minority coalition and it was
going to be durable and it was going to
stick together the intersectional
coalition was going to stick together
and it turns out that that fell apart in
2016 when the intersectional coalition
didn't show up for hillary
well it turns out the intersectional
coalition also did not show up for
democrats in congress
the intersectional coalition may have
shown up because they don't like donald
trump very much
but they did not show up to get rid of
susan collins in maine they did not show
up to get rid of tom tillis in north
carolina they did not show up to get rid
of steve dayne's in montana
they did not show up to get rid of john
cornyn in texas
in fact the opposite happened a bunch of
those suburban women turned back to
back into republicans in 2020. in fact
donald trump got an outsized share of
latino and black votes
and so democrats are looking at each
other going wait a second are you the
enemy are you the problem here
because here is the problem the
democrats have some fundamentally
incompatible
demographics in their coalition i'm not
talking about racial demographics i'm
talking about ideological demographics
so you've got the
the squad who are declaring that
socialism is the way forward and then
you've got
purple district democrats who are like
hold up just a second
you're going to get me kicked out of
congress you've got
aoc suggesting socialism is the way
forward and then you've got latino
voters down in florida cuban voters and
venezuelan voters
going hold up we just came from a
socialist country and you are a crazy
person that is not a thing i want
you got a bunch of woke white people who
are saying to black people defund the
police and black people looking at them
like are you insane
we need cops in our towns are you nuts
you've got a bunch of people
in the democratic party who believe that
the top issue in america is
allowing biological boys into girls
locker rooms and meanwhile i got a bunch
of working-class white people going i
don't have a job
this coalition cannot hold together it
is fragmenting and that was perfectly
obvious
from the tone and tenor from the
democratic party they are in a state of
sheer panic right now
the only thing masking the panic is the
fact that they think biden won that's
the only thing asking the panic right
now
because when you get behind the scenes
the panic is absolutely obvious so
here's the proof
democratic caucus call yesterday so
there's a congresswoman named abigail
spanberger she's from virginia she ran
in a very very tight race
okay and she was sounding off
she was sounding off on her election
battle
okay she is she she won her race by
something like 5 000 votes out of 450
000 votes cast over nick freitas
okay if that ends up being the final
margin she said quote we lost races we
shouldn't have lost
defund police almost cost me my race
because of an attack ad don't say
socialism ever again
need to get back to basics is yelling
right this is erica werner washington
post congressional reporter is yelling
i love that i love that okay if we run
this race again we will get effing torn
apart in 2022 spanberger says
okay then nancy pelosi who has run this
party directly into the ground remember
her great legislative achievement
under donald trump is a failed
impeachment that's it
you can't name any of the other things
because they don't exist pelosi came
back on and says she disagrees they won
the house in the presidency
you lost seats in a year you were
supposed to pick up seats lady
okay you may not have won the presidency
we'll find out if you did it was by the
narrowest possible margin over a
candidate you guys said was so
historically unpopular
that joe biden was going to win 55 of
the votes and 400 electoral votes
and then pelosi says we have a mandate
we have a mandate
first of all i hope that nancy pelosi
believes that i hope that the house
democrats decide they're going to push
forward
with let's force your kindergarten to
learn that
that sally has two moms i i seriously i
hope that this is the democratic party
platform moving forward
green new deal transgender rights like
do it go for it go for broke on the
cultural issues
do it i'm i'm begging you do it
yes good good
also earlier in the call debbie
mccarsell powell who lost her race in
florida was crying and
she mentioned how people can't pronounce
her name and said stop being negative on
twitter then hakeem jeffries came back
on to tell people to stop leaking
and that reporters aren't your friends
then representative jayapal came on and
told jefferies to find the leakers
erica werner says it just keeps going as
pascarel now calling out schumer
pelosi's done an amazing job but where
schumer in all this says pelosi has one
hand tied behind her back rashida to
leave says before we make painful
statements we need to wait and see how
the numbers come down
feels like i'm being asked to be quiet
and we need to appeal to certain people
and that's not right
so talib is like you're trying to
silence me you're one of the loudest
members of congress you're trying to
silence me
then talib says they called obama worse
they called him a muslim a socialist you
can blame these words but if it wasn't
on blm
it would have been on something else
okay no the the reason it didn't work on
obama is because
obama was not in fact easily paintable
as a socialist
you guys decided to run bernie sanders
the honorable estima alexandra ocosm
ocasio-cortez was a registered member of
the democratic socialists of america
and declared socialism is a good idea
barack obama never did that because he's
not an idiot you guys are idiots
okay that is the problem so
so that's pretty hilarious okay and then
so joe biden has a mandate said speaker
pelosi
and then jared huffman who's a congress
person from california
tweeted out some of my colleagues are
literally live leaking our internal
democratic caucus right now to cnn the
hill nbc political et cetera i've gotten
texts from three different reporters
asking me to lively juicy details to
them no we
dems and the media need to stop this
nonsense
so first of all i i've been informed
that leakers are patriots
all of them so i don't know what he's
complaining about second
if you're a democratic congress person
you could easily be forgiven for
believing that members of the media are
your friends
because they are because they defend
everything you do
this is a major problem for the
democrats that coalition is not going to
hold
that coalition is is falling apart in
fact
because it turns out the people they
should be listening to like abigail
spanberger are being cast out by the
people from pure blue districts like aoc
democrats will never lose brooklyn
democrats could easily lose
spamber's seat in virginia she almost
lost her seat to
a republican in a very very purple
district
in a in what was supposed to be a bad
year for republicans
okay so that is going to break out into
the open but democrats have no capacity
to run away from it that's the part
that's hilarious
so this crystallized most of all in an
exchange that happened yesterday
via twitter and other places claire
mccaskill
former senator from missouri she was on
msnbc and she says
the problem with the democratic party is
you guys are ignoring all the issues
people care about in favor of your
culture war bull crap
here's claire mccaskill pointing out the
perfectly obvious
the republican party i think very uh
adroitly
adopted cultural issues as part of their
main theme
whether you're talking guns or issues
surrounding the right to abortion in
this country
or things like gay marriage and the
right for transsexuals and
and other people who we as a party have
tried to
quote unquote look after and make sure
that they're treated fairly
as we you know circled those issues we
left some voters behind and republicans
dove in with a vengeance okay so she is
right about all of that right you dove
into the cultural issues you ignored the
needs of your own constituents
right this is a proper take in an
election remember democrats were
supposed to win walking away they did
not win
walking away the simple fact of the
matter is that if everybody
who voted republican for congress voted
for president
trump in wisconsin he would have won
wisconsin there are 49
000 voters in wisconsin who voted
republican on house ballots who didn't
vote for trump
at the top of the ticket conversely
there were 69 000 democrats who voted in
wisconsin
and voted for joe biden at the top of
the ticket and did not vote for a
democrat down ballot
which means that there are a lot of
people who do not want democrats in
control there are a lot of people who
may not have liked president trump very
much
and so that's masking the democrats
utter failure the other night
but that is a very shallow mask okay and
claire mccaskill is pointing out that
our coalition is not a durable coalition
right so
what is the response of the squad of the
honorable alexander ocasio-cortez again
i keep calling her this because she has
declared that despite the fact that her
twitter handle is aoc we can't call her
aoc because that's disrespectful to her
and to women everywhere or some such
nonsense
and having been accused of catcalling
her for simply suggesting that we have a
debate
now uh alexander ocasio-cortez has
declared you can't call her aoc so now
i call her the honorable representative
the honorable estimable
brilliant representative alexander
ocasio-cortez d twitch
she tweeted out why do we listen to
people who lost elections as if they are
expert in winning elections
mccaskill tried her approach she ran as
a caravan hysteria den
and lost while grassroots organizers won
progressive measures in missouri
her language here shows how she took her
base for granted
oh please listen to the honorable estima
representative ocasio-cortez please
listen to her democrats
the the wonders and wisdom of this woman
beyond the pale beyond the pale
i just i love the fact that claire
mccaskill lost in missouri to a
republican
and aoc is like you know what sorry
alexandra oscar cortez honorable
estimate twitch
she says that mccaskill lost because she
didn't campaign as a hard-left
democratic socialist
in missouri please keep listening to
that
do it do it and kermit the frog meme
do it i'm begging you democrats listen
to alexandria ocasio-cortez
continue along these lines suggest that
claire mccaskill is wrong
the culture war issues the socialism all
of this is a good idea
follow the squad down the rabbit hole
see here's the problem for the democrats
this is a real problem for the democrats
they decided they were going to they're
they're a dying party in some ways
that they're going to live off the
lifeblood of the intersectional
coalition
like a seven-year-old hollywood
celebrity bringing in a 20 year old and
then
having their blood filtered to them
right that's that's what the democratic
party has become
almost literally right you've got 95
year old nancy pelosi trying to live off
the life energy
of alexander ocasio-cortez and posing
with her and ilhan omar and rashida
talib on the cover of rolling stone
magazine
right that that is that is the vibe okay
well it turns out
what happens if uh the 20 year old that
whose blood you are living off of
what happens if that 20 year old has um
a blood disease
what then that's the problem gang
they have decided they're going to live
off the energy of the woke socialists
and the woke socialists are not going to
be complacent just being part of the
coalition
they want to drive the bus and because
you need them you cannot alienate them
and that's why nancy pelosi refuses to
acknowledge that the other night was a
bad night for democrats even though
everybody knows it was a bad night for
democrats
if they acknowledge it was a bad night
for democrats and that campaigning on
black lives matter
and the police are racist and defund the
police and socialism is good
and transgender bathrooms and everybody
who doesn't like me is a racist that's a
bad campaign strategy the minute they
acknowledge that they implicitly rebuke
the squad but they need the squad they
can't alienate the squad
see what's happened here is a process
that the author nicholas nassim talib
has called renormalization so
renormalization is the idea that if you
have
an extremely solid core of a small group
of supporters who are intransigent in
their beliefs
they can force everybody over to their
side so take for example is the example
that talib uses
take for example you have a family with
one daughter who's a vegetarian
and that daughter who's a vegetarian
says to mom listen i'm a vegetarian you
can eat what you want but i'm not eating
anything you put on the table that's not
vegetarian so mom now has two choices
she can either cook two meals
one friend transgender vegetarian
daughter and one for everybody else or
she can just cook a vegetarian meal for
everybody and then let's say that that
family goes to a block party
and there are 20 families there and the
family says listen our daughter she's
vegetarian
you can just make one meal for her
that's vegetarian but we're all kind of
eating vegetarian in solidarity
and so you know you can make two meals
just give us the vegetarian meal and
everybody else has the non-vegetarian
meal
and so the organizers of the party they
go you know what it's not that much of a
cost for us just to order one meal and
it's kind of a hassle to have to
organize too so now everybody's eating
vegetarian because this one person
is intransigent that's the squad the
squad has said that we are willing to
walk the squad has said we are willing
to take down members of our own potty
party the squad has said we want to rule
the roost and we refuse to take a back
seat to anybody including the so-called
moderates that we need
and so we are going to take over the
party and nancy pelosi has no ability to
defend against this
particularly because they can use their
tactics against nancy pelosi they can
call nancy pelosi an old white racist
they can suggest she's out of touch they
can suggest she's too conservative even
though she's a san francisco liberal
it's pretty incredible so the democrats
have a world of hurt coming to them
conor lamb is making that clear as an
article in the washington post today
centrist house democrats lash out at
liberal colleagues blame far-left views
for costing the party seats
an angry dispute erupted among house
democrats on thursday with
with centrist members blasting their
liberal colleagues during a private
conference call
for pushing far-left views that cost the
party seats in tuesday's election that
they had worked hard to win two years
ago
the bitter exchange which lasted more
than three hours as members sniped back
and forth over tactics and ideology
reflected the extent to which the 220
campaign exposed
similar intentions in the party even as
its presidential nominee joe biden
stands on the brink of achieving their
biggest goal of the year ousting
president trump but here's the thing it
was never about asking trump and this is
what i said yesterday
for democrats i i'm old enough to
remember because i'm more than 30
seconds old when democrats said
the only thing that would save our souls
is ousting trump if trump remains in
office
the world is lost now they think the
biden has won the election
and yet they are deeply unhappy why
because it was never about their disdain
for trump's character or the fact that
he was violating norms or anything like
that they didn't care about any of that
that was all an excuse to get rid of
trump and hopefully to get rid of
republicans across the country who they
were trying to tie to trump right that
was their whole campaign it turns out
americans didn't hate trump enough for
that and they didn't hate republicans
enough for that and they really really
hate the wolksters
they really hate the welksters that is
the message of the election you know who
knows that
everybody who's in a moderate district
other centrists like
mark vici of texas made similar points
liberals meanwhile fired back
representative pamila jayapal democrat
of washington and chair
co-chairwoman of the congressional
progressive caucus argued that democrats
should not single out people on ideas
that energize the party based
rashida talib accused her colleagues of
only being interested in appealing to
white people
in suburbia there it is there it is all
the democrats on the call are also
racists
who only care about the white racists in
the suburbs according to rashida talib
you guys decided to feed the alligator
hoping you'd eat you lasted ain't it's
eating it first
how does that feel how's it feel having
those alligator teeth wrapped right
around your sternum
you enjoying that are you yeah you had
that coming
to be real it sounds like you were
saying stop pushing for what black folks
want
said rashida talib throughout the call
pelosi sought to reassure her remembers
the election wasn't as bad as it seemed
democrats charged have held on to about
70 of the 30 trump carry districts they
won in 2018.
she says we held the house we didn't win
every battle we did win the war no you
lost seats
you lost seats okay democrats messaging
is terrible it doesn't resonate to
representative kurt schrader a democrat
of oregon a member of the blue dog
coalition when voters see the far left
that gets all the news media attention
they get scared they're afraid this will
become a super nanny state and their
ability to do things on their own is
going to be taking
is going to take things away several
moderate democrats in
said in interviews that pelosi should
have made a deal with trump on a
coronavirus relief package
pelosi said she was holding back for a
better deal but it was a huge mistake
one one lawmaker said it made us look
like obstructionists instead of those
up for the challenge the country needs
it was a huge mistake trump was like i'm
ready for a deal make it bigger and
pelosi was obstructing
representative sherry bustos democrat of
illinois the chairwoman of the dccc who
nearly lost her seat
is also facing member wrath she defended
her operation argued
that republicans were forced to spend
tens of millions of dollars playing
defense
but that's not true republicans want a
bunch of seats they weren't supposed to
win
privately democrats and interviews
according to the washington post cannot
make
privately democrats in interviews over
the past two days have said the answer
is obvious the party in recent years has
moved further left with some members
embracing such liberal ideas as free
college the green new deal eliminating
the filibuster and adding justices to
the supreme court
many of the houses rank and file support
those policies
though pelosi and the dccc have done
their utmost to steer the caucus away
from those
ideas at the same time one member noted
130 house democrats face primaries this
cycle
with such groups as justice democrats
defeating establishment democrats
seeking to punish members who aren't
liberal enough
one lawmaker said there's no question
that was a huge albatross on the next of
so many of our candidates who
unfortunately went down
there has to be a reckoning within our
ranks about this because a lot of
justice democrats don't give a damn
about the democratic party they're all
about purity and orthodoxy
and it is damaging our opportunities
meanwhile the executive director of
justice democrats alexandre rojas
she said they had one job and they blew
it we need a democratic party that
stands for something more than just
being
anti-trump conor lamb a centrist who
barely won his seat on election day said
spanberger was talking about something
many of us are feeling today we pay the
price for these
unprofessional and unrealistic comments
about a number of issues whether it is
about police or shale gas
these issues are too serious for people
we represent to tolerate them being
talked about so casually
correct correct but do you think the
democrats can let go of it you bet your
ass they cannot let go of it they will
never be able to let go of it ever
because again they are too attached to
the message that everyone who opposes
them
only opposes them because they're racist
they can never look at a trump voter or
even a crossover voter who voted for
biden and then republican down ballot
or somebody who didn't vote for trump at
the top of the ticket voted republican
down ballot they cannot let go of the
argument the only reason to vote against
democrats is because
you are a racist this is why you saw
late night host lamenting america last
night here a bunch of late night house
lamenting
the state of america and listen listen
honestly
like when i am looking for moral
guidance the people i look to most
are late night comedians they're the
people when i look to the future of
america i think jimmy kimmel
jimmy fallon stephen colbert these are
the people i look to as the moral light
of our time the torchbearers for decency
here are our late-night hosts lamenting
that america is so terrible so horrible
so bad and then they go back to their
palatial estates where they don't have
to worry about any of these issues
protected by private security he is a
liar
and a cheat who wants them to stop
counting thousands of legitimate votes
and almost half of us are apparently
okay with that be careful america
if you let trump do this then voting
could soon become one of those things
that people do to feel better but
doesn't actually do anything as usual
the state that got us into this mess was
florida every four years democrats hope
they'll take it
but once again last night florida was
called for donald trump
florida's officially america's cheating
boyfriend
why do we always think we can change him
okay yeah you guys
this is the way to win this is the way
to win call everyone you don't like a
dupe or an idiot or a racist
go for it just go for it enjoy and see
how it goes for you
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise
we will see you here on monday for all
of the latest sure to be a very lively
weekend so try to take it a little bit
easy we'll be back here to recap it all
for you
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavel wydowsky
our associate producers are nick sheehan
and rebecca doyle the show is edited by
adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen